Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get to the mailbag for the week.
You can write info at David Pakman dot com
if you have something to say.
A question, a comment, a complaint, a demand
for an apology or a retraction, which are
very, very frequent on the program.
Sometimes we'll also highlight a YouTube comment
or a Twitter message or something else.
I do want to you know, I keep getting the
question.
Speaker 3: David.
Speaker 1: David, are you getting hit with
more anti-Semitism since the carnage?
Nick Fuentes stuff has sort of been mainstreamed.
I get a lot of anti-Semitism anyway, but it's
definitely higher and more frequent and people
just seem more willing to say certain things.
Here's just like one example Paul wrote on
YouTube David Pakman shameless Jew who often
has a hard on that he is proud of this idea
of a shameless Jew is, you know, it's not
like you're using the k-word, but this is
actually a pretty gross thing, which is the
idea that you should be ashamed if you are
a Jew.
As Paul says here, and a lot of these ideas
are very pervasive among the anti-Semitic
right.
You should be ashamed.
You should have said you shouldn't leave your
house.
You shouldn't have a YouTube channel.
Certainly you should be hiding your face and
hiding out in general.
But yes, significant amounts of anti-Semitism
since and I believe as a result of as a result
of the normalization of such anti-Semitism
due to some pretty prominent people, including
Kanye.
Next message is from Lulu app also coming
to us from YouTube, Lou app says Pacman, you
are a car.
Me, why do you not move to China?
Well.
I'm not a communist.
I don't speak any Chinese dialect.
I don't know anybody in China, and I have
no interest in moving to China.
Why are you trying to change America to a
communist system?
I'm not.
I'm not a communist.
Just move, MAGA.
We'll never let this country change without.
Now these are capitalized, just like Trump
does.
Major dust up.
Prepare yourself.
It is coming now.
Of course, this is an allusion to violence.
It's important to understand when folks say
we're going to do a lot to prevent this country
from becoming communist.
They're talking about violence.
They're not talking about signing a petition.
They're not talking about a letter writing
campaign.
They're talking about violence, often involving
firearms.
And now, at the same time, the U.S. isn't
actually about to become communist.
So I don't really know that anything's going
to happen because that's not going on.
Let's go next from YouTube over to Facebook.
Facebook, where Greg wrote in and said, you
are the biggest hypocrite on everything.
Democrats are taking the law and order form
this great country.
People like you are the problem.
Typical Democrat.
Now we've talked about the law and order stuff
a bunch now.
The right loves to say we are for free speech.
We never want to censor or limit speech until
they do.
And then you go on truth social and you see
that you're not allowed to post about the
January 6th insurrection, depending on what
you post and on and on and on there for speech,
but not really.
Well, they are certainly against regulating
businesses, right.
Businesses must be allowed to do whatever
they want all the time.
We're against regulating businesses.
Oh, but.
No, but.
Social media.
Social media platforms, though, should be
forced to publish our right wing messages.
Social media platforms should be regulated
to be forced to publish our COVID disinformation.
But we're against regulating businesses.
And then, of course, we get you.
We are for law and order.
Well, on January 6th, hundreds of your people
committed all sorts of different crimes in
Washington, D.C..
And now your concern isn't let's make sure
we prosecute lawbreakers.
It's their being treated unfairly.
They shouldn't be held in pretrial detention
and on and on and on.
All of these are just talking points.
They don't mean any of it.
They're not really the party of law and order.
Jordan wrote in and said, Are you deaf and
idiot?
And then they said, here's a suggestion.
Go get your brain checked out.
You Democrat loving loser.
This will be the last one of this style and
then we'll get on to more substantive stuff.
The reason I highlight this one continues
to be.
I'm not a Democrat.
I don't care about the Democratic Party.
I see the Democratic Party essentially as
a corporation whose primary objective is its
own self-preservation and self-aggrandizement.
I see it as having worthier political goals
than the Republican Party.
Yes, but I'm not a Democrat, and quite frankly,
I don't care about the Democratic Party.
And yet I regularly get messages like this,
which, by the way, conflict with you're a
communist.
The actual communists hate the Democratic
Party.
They see it as almost indistinguishable from
the Republican Party and a tool of all the
same special interests.
So am I a Communist, a group that hates the
Democratic Party?
Or am I a Democrat?
I'm actually neither.
I'm an unaffiliated when it comes to political
party.
Social Democrat.
That's what I am.
It's very, very simple.
Okay.
Next message is from Grant.
Grant brings up a great question about LGBT
community title and says, Hello, David, I've
noticed you've recently started using the
term LGBTQ.
Instead of LGBT to refer to the community.
I'm curious what inspired you to make the
adjustment?
Should this be a change that all of us in
the progressive movement adopt?
Or is it simply a personal preference?
I'm happy to make a correction in my speech
if necessary.
Hope you and your loved ones are fully recovered
from COVID.
Thanks for your hard work and excellent content.
You know, I didn't even know.
I don't.
I'm not.
In my mind, I still say LGBT.
But I guess it is true.
I've used LGBTQ to some degree recently.
I think part of it may be if I'm reading an
article, if I if we're using as a source an
article that says LGBTQ.
I will say LGBTQ.
I know I believe the Q means queer, which
I think is more of a it's a vague term.
It's not.
Oh, well, I'm I'm a lesbian.
Okay.
So, okay.
You're a woman attracted to other women.
I think Q is queer and it's a more general
term.
I'm glad to include it.
In my mind, I use the term LGBT.
I think everybody knows what community I'm
talking about and certainly I whichever term
I'm using, I'm not trying to exclude anyone.
That's that's for sure.
Okay.
Divergent views among my audience about the
Brittney Griner situation.
Many of you do not think that she should have
been brought home in this prisoner swap.
Here is someone, Mike, who wrote in about
the clown show and says, David, Brittney Griner
should be compelled to finish her incarceration
in an American prison now that she's been
released from Russian custody, thanks to President
Biden.
What a clown show.
Let's all feel sorry for a jock who deliberately
flaunted Russian law.
I think you mean flouted.
Actually flouted Russian law.
Got caught, tried in a Russian court, sentenced
only to be released because of President Biden's
negotiations.
What a effing joke.
Short and pithy enough.
Well, it doesn't really make sense that she
finished her sentence in the U.S. because.
What she did.
Speaker 3: In.
Speaker 1: The U.S. What she did is differently
criminalized than in Russia.
So it doesn't really make sense.
It's sort of like saying, oh, someone was
gay in another country that criminalizes being
gay.
We got them out.
But now they should finish their sentence.
In the U.S..
Well, in the US, being gay is in a crime,
so that doesn't really make any sense.
Now, I do understand people having the view
that this was the wrong intervention for Joe
Biden to make, that it's actually Paul Whelan
who should have been freed, etc., but serve
the rest of his sentence here.
That doesn't make any sense.
Part of why the U.S. intervened was because
the sentence was deemed to be unfairly harsh.
Okay.
Spencer wrote in about religion and says,
Hi, David, do you think Jews are better people
than Christians?
Oh, come on, guys.
I don't think they commit very many crimes
in the USA and I've never heard of a Jewish
terrorist.
I'm sure much of the hate in the USA is from
Christians, whereas Jews are more tolerant
people.
So first of all, I'm against the idea of better
So no, I don't think Jews are better people
than Christians.
I think all people are is, as we might see,
individuals who do immoral things, which we
criticize.
But the idea of groups of people that are
better, that this is this is not the way I
think about things.
So.
So I would not know.
Know it's a no from me inter.
Let's just leave it there.
It's an interesting message, but one I'm not
sure what else to say about J. Fran made a
YouTube comment and says, Well said, David,
as a Jew, this sorry, this is about the Kanye
anti-Semitism.
Look, J France as well.
So, David, as a Jew, this at first was goofy,
but it's quickly become extremely disturbing
and honestly frightening having Kanye as a
massive cultural figure and influence in society.
I see many people now repeating Kanye's rhetoric,
and I'm very worried this will just continue
to escalate.
Yeah, you know, there's a lot of people who
are arguing and sometimes they'll write in.
Who cares what a musical artist and designer
clothing designer Kanye says about Jews?
Just don't pay any attention.
Just ignore him.
That's it.
But the unfortunate reality is, not only does
Kanye have a very large megaphone, not because
of the coverage of his anti-Semitism, but
because of his own megaphone.
But also a lot of the people that are hearing
his message about Jews are people who are
a much a blank slate.
Folks that listen to like my show, for example,
are probably aware of the history of anti-Semitism,
and they've sort of been inoculated to it
because they already understand a lot of these
talking points and anti-Semitism.
Imagine that you aren't familiar with that
history.
And suddenly Kanye, a musical artist you admire
or maybe a clothing designer, you really like
the pants that he designed or something like
that, or the boots.
I don't know.
You don't really have any protection against
this disinformation.
And Kanye saying the Jews are controlling
this and they're conspiring to control that.
And they did this bad thing to me.
And a Jewish doctor tried to get me killed
by giving me medication, all the stuff that
starts to become your worldview.
So I actually do think it is very important,
very important to take it head on and to do
everything we can to prevent Kanye from becoming
the authority on Jews in the minds of many
of these people.
That's my view.
I think Jay Efron is saying something very
similar.
We have such a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join pacman dot com.
Get instant access and we will see you then
with the coupon code.
24 starts now because it did.
24 is off of running.
We will see you then.